it's hard to see actor rert Grant
without thinking Ron Weasley the lucky
group of actors who landed the main
roles in the Harry Potter film series
quickly became synonymous with the
famous literary characters and no matter
how many amazing films Emma Watson stars
in She'll always be Hermione in our
hearts these stars are so in tune with
their on-screen characters that we
started wondering what their fictional
alter egos would have looked like as
kids or what about babies and toddlers
here's what the cast of Harry Potter
looks like reimagined as adorable babies
let's start with the star of the show
The Boy Who Lived the one and only Harry
Potter you're a wizard Harry in the
first film of the franchise Daniel
Radcliffe took on the titular role
surprising fans with his ability to
capture the character from the series
the actor was just 11 years old when he
began playing Harry and going back to
that first movie is like a time capsule
for fans how cute was he but if Harry
had have started at Hogwarts a few years
earlier not much would have changed baby
Harry still has the classic messy mopa
hair awkwardly large glasses and an
endearing smile okay now we're seriously
into the idea of a Hogwarts preschool
prequel am I right next up is Harry's
bestie till the end played by Emma
Watson the young actress landed the role
at just 9 years old turning 10 before
filming began she perfectly captured the
frizzy-haired know-it-all Hermione from
the books fans know that Hermione
constantly had her nose in the books
aspiring to learn every single spell and
potion that exists so it's no surprise
that baby Hermione is hard at work on a
spell and her hair is as wild as ever
can you just picture this little cutie
telling Ron it's Le Oar not leviar and
speaking of Ron now we're moving on to
Harry's right-hand man just like the
other two in his Trio of Pals Ron
Weasley was a fan favorite from the
get-go and the red head from the huge
family was perfectly portrayed by then
12-year-old Rupert Grant though he was
slightly older than some of his
castmates he still had a baby face which
helped him play the little
troublemaker and just look at actual
baby Ron Weasley he was clearly already
aspiring to a career on the quidditch
field with a toddler sized uniform and a
golden snitch ready and waiting if you
made it to the end of the series you
know that we do get to see the hard show
teacher seus Snape as a young pupil of
Hogwarts during some of the flashback
scenes so it makes sense that even as a
younger kid Snape rocked the same Shaggy
black hairo we have to say the scary
Snape who Harry made an enemy of early
on looks a lot less threatening as a
little kid Harry's arch nemesis Maloy on
screen Draco Malfoy was played by Tom
Felton who turned 13 during the filming
of the first movie The Blonde bad boy of
Slytherin that many fans had a soft spot
for particularly due to his striking
good looks was just as cute as a baby
now we're all in for the Hogwarts
toddler series with white-haired baby
Maloy looking this cute being from one
of the OG wizard families it makes sense
that baby Draco was already quite handy
with a wand who would have guessed that
awkward and bumbling Neville long bottom
why is it always me would turn out to be
one of the biggest Heroes of the series
it's hard to believe especially looking
at this side character turned hero as a
fresh-faced toddler portrayed by actor
Matthew Lewis in the film franchise the
stars real life glow up mirrored long
bottoms rise to importance in the series
in the last few films Lewis even had to
wear padding under his costume and Dawn
false crooked teeth as the actor was
getting too good-looking to play the
awkward Neville but I mean how can you
not love Neville at any age being one of
the youngest of the Hogwarts group
Little Jenny Weasley wasn't even old
enough to attend Hogwarts yet when the
series began in the first film we saw
her only for a few minutes as the family
saw Ron off for year one good luck but
as the series progressed actress Bonnie
Wright came into her own much like Jenny
giving the powerful character some oomph
though we already know what Jenny looked
like as a kid it's no surprise that
Harry's future wifey was even more
adorable as a baby you just know there
are some big plans going on behind those
big round eyes oh Luna who doesn't enjoy
a bit of Looney strange odd Luna
unfortunately all my shoes have
mysteriously disappeared the fictional
character from the series was expanded
for the screen once saana Lynch signed
on to play the quirky Luna love good and
she instantly became a fan favorite
anytime she pops up on the screen to add
her two cents to Harry Ron and
Hermione's Adventures you can't help but
Smile as a toddler Luna was obviously
just as goofy sporting some funky lunet
I mean glasses Baby Luna would clear
clearly make a great addition to
Hogwarts preschool the series so now
that we know what these characters would
look like as kids well little kids it's
really hard to imagine any other actors
reprising the roles of the Beloved
characters created by JK ring though
we're all bracing ourselves for the
inevitable remake of the series I'd much
rather see a prequel showcasing these
magical witches and wizards as adorable
toddlers hey Hollywood it's an idea so
which of these Harry Potter characters
is cutest as a baby I know it's going to
be hard to choose but leave us your
thoughts in the comments and let us know
what you'd like to see these characters
reimagined as
next